rest in peace the last of the Marvel
Netflix superhero series on Monday
February 18th 2019 deadline delivered
harrowing news the masses both The
Punisher and Jessica Jones have been
canceled at Netflix the two streaming
shows that stood strong after Netflix
pulled the plug on Luke Cage iron fist
and the much-loved daredevil in an
unprecedented act swinging session in
late 2018 the Punisher and Jessica Jones
helped make up the Marvel television
corner of the streamers content library
their cancellations mean that there are
no longer any non canceled Netflix back
to Marvel shows on the platform The
Punisher Zach sing comes just a month
after the series aired its highly
anticipated second season to critical
praise and fun fare from loyal viewers
the standing plans about Jessica Jones
season 3 will air sometime later this
year giving the series a chance to wrap
up its story which the Punisher sadly
didn't get to do around the time formal
word got out punisher star Jon Bernthal
took to his Instagram account to address
the show's cancellation saying in parts
to all who have served all who know
lasts all who love and understand Frank
in his pain it has been an honor to walk
in his boots I'm endlessly grateful to
the comic fans and the men and women of
the armed services and law enforcement
community who Frank means so much to
Marvel television had honcho Jeph Loeb
append a letter to Marvel fans thanking
them for supporting all the shows he
said in part our partner may have
decided they no longer want to continue
telling the tales of these great
characters but you know Marvel better
than that as Matthew Murdock's dad once
said the measure of a man is not how he
gets knocked to the mats
it's how he gets back up Loeb teased at
the very end of its letter that the
stories may not completely be over yet
writing to be continued this double
cancellation comes as Disney which owns
Marvel Studios and a small screen armed
Marvel TV prepares to roll out its
upcoming direct-to-consumer streaming
platform at Disney Plus the company has
several projects brewing including
multiple series centered on Marvel
Cinematic Universe heroes vision and
Scarlet Witch Loki and Falcon and the
Winter Soldier popular speculation is
that Netflix is cutting ties with the
Marvel series so that Disney can
potentially scoop up the shows provide
them and air them on Disney Plus
alongside the other Marvel shows however
there are two factors complicating this
light
first according to variety there is
reportedly a clause in the original
agreement between Marvel TV and Netflix
for Luke Cage iron-fisted Daredevil and
Jessica Jones that legally bars Marvel
TV from using any of the series
characters in an on Netflix show or TV
movie for at least two years post
cancellation and second according to
Deadline Lobo recently entered a deal
for four television series Panda special
with none other than Hulu another
massive streamer if what we know about
the terms of Marvel's TV deals have
Netflix is correct fans shouldn't expect
to see any of the Marvel Netflix series
get resurrected for Hulu Disney Plus or
any other platform for at least two
years according to The Hollywood
Reporter Netflix quote did not have any
ownership stake in its Marvel superhero
shows all of which were owned by Disney
Netflix canceling Jessica Jones and The
Punisher now plus the three other solo
shows last year signifies that Disney is
hoping to reclaim the series that it
doesn't have direct possession over and
those are the ones on Netflix sad as
everyone may be over Netflix doing away
with the Punisher and Jessica Jones the
two silver linings here are that Jessica
Jones will still release a third season
and that we certainly haven't seen the
last of Byrne Thor who will appear in
the many Saints of Newark New Line
Cinema's and development prequel to The
Sopranos additionally all signs are
pointing to Disney as a future of Marvel
TV fare with executives at both Disney
and Marvel having reportedly stated that
quote the canceled Netflix fare could
live again on Disney Plus check out one
of our newest videos right here Plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]